okay babies it's your boy psychobabble
and um we're back and we are about to do
this question is right here okay so
let's do it
or a very close very close and you know
what instead of man one those here to
where is that like get you right there
and start let's start the video at the
quest like it's like okay like oops oops
god I just like so long a little girl
okay I'm not my first time in this game
of course that's getting um and hair
where you go let's do this hello
what do you want one is up for it this
thing is where's my horse ain't Raj
there is oh my god just out of nowhere
yes I know let's go let's go let's go
add some paint ball up I guess
pulsating stir disgusting where's that
put this horsey slower what now faster
Jesus eyes it's on down okay we're down
there anyway how's that one standard I'm
pretty good good good good gun that's
what I like to hear that's a type of
interaction I like to get my friends you
know and I got lots of hands okay I got
more friends than you could ever imagine
you know just buying me things you know
whatever it's like hello like you don't
need to buy me like this car to show you
you're a fan like it I like he's gay
oh my god you gotta be kidding me
or the wrong one
Yeah right yeah at least we're closed
I'll let so just feet away all right
back over here I gotta say if they feel
like we've been here before like deja vu
you know that cat's got right here let's
go right here you know we should make a
little zig zag over here and then we're
fine you're fine man they're like bodies
hanging all over the place up on this
gentleman is this like like New York
centers or what okay I think what the
spot Wow they're right there
this is disgusting kind of cut up cut up
cut cut cut
go get that guy
all right they going
okay how do I bring this thing all right
guys that it that's it right there that
is my job yeah that's right okay agnate
perfect ow I can't sit guys gotta cut
these bodies disgusting master huh I got
this one that I got next my next one
Terry 50 feet what yeah
oh no am i walking that chicken trays in
the way wretch go on Jesus
okay I get in there again there
huh holy crap what that hack frickin
wall dogs everywhere
ah yes stupid animal this guy is like
pretty fast okay
now watch hey guys were out just fine
that's disgusting where's that bloat
thing where there yeah okay last place
last place all right come on Roger
ah-ah-ah
cap cap freakin burning out here
today we do this shortcuts a nice
shortcut right here the secret is to not
use any pads because they just lie down
not Jesus okay okay we should be there
in a second okay I think is it yeah
these girls are easy to count
anytime baby
I only burn this and I'll get that Prius
gosh man get dark quick in here
okay let me get all these know what is
this transparent dot my knife hideout
you know okay
ashes okay let me just meditate a real
quick yeah that's good friggin dark
thank you hi Suraj
yeah freakin far away all right are you
doing senator Bay you got nothing better
I don't must be nice out that my job you
know okay we're running straight there
babbling strike they're freaking dogs
running after us
here's about the right identity oh crap
Santa's a couple of bet okay
what's gals go I mean it's gotta forget
dark out here no I knew right no that's
a really good like architecture
Landscape Architecture I guess oh they
did a good job got a mint
the hell is this there's so many doors
Liz you know you ever do seconds doesn't
pop them and you can't like just like I
guess you can't just skip it button okay
time to annihilate this fool took care
of the graves interesting actually one
of the corpses have ever been ass alive
and pretty talkative yeah
I don't tank bribes that's gonna baby
you like that okay well I guess you know
I guess there's another happy ending for
that which I you know another happy
ending anyways thanks for watching y'all
thank you